[Musica]
attivista per i diritti umani o
supereroi Io mi sono sempre definita un
attivista per i diritti umani sono
attivista dal dai tempi del liceo avevo
14 anni quando ho cominciato
a parlare a conoscere il mondo dei
diritti umani e mi sono sempre occupata
di fare educazione diritti umani no
andavo nelle scuole quindi attraverso la
Pira Education andiamo nelle scuole e a
spiegare cosa fossero i diritti umani
Poi crescendo li ho studiati
all'università e poi mi sono occupata
anche di formazione professionale e non
vi dico quanto sia difficile spiegare
alla alle persone Voi cosa siano i
diritti umani non addetti ai lavori e
detti lavori è facile No È semplice
parlare di giusnaturalismo della Beats
Corpus i diritti positivi diritti
relativi ai diritti assoluti
l'universalità dei diritti umani i
diritti di prima generazione seconda
generazione fantastica quando si sono
questi incontri è tutto molto bello ci
si confronta ci si capisce parlando di
questi argomenti così
Dotti però ci si allontana dai diritti
umani è quello di cui mi sono resa conto
perché in realtà andando nelle scuole e
parlando di dei diritti umani in questi
termini io perdevo e ci perdevano i
diritti umani perché
quando sono andata in una scuola non una
ma tante nelle zone più depresse delle
nostre città un ragazzino mi fa E chi
studia diritto male si mangiano No non
si mangiano i diritti umani però proprio
perché sono di tutti bisogna farli
capire a tutti
e io ho avuto questa difficoltà ho detto
Come posso fare per riuscire Se mi sento
un attivista per i diritti umani Come
posso fare per raggiungere Questo
obiettivo comunicativo che poi in realtà
Comprendiamo bene come da un semplice
obiettivo comunicativo che potrebbe
essere in realtà poi diventa un
obiettivo di cambiamento della società
perché ci si rende conto di cosa sono i
propri diritti e che i diritti umani
sono di tutti
indistintamente Ah sia che io abito qui
che io abiti in Sri Lanka piuttosto che
in Honduras
Bene
durante la mia formazione a un certo
punto è nella mia attività come soci
appunto è attivista ho incontrato me
l'ha insegnato una una ragazza
lojain
e lei lei non mi conosce Io la conosco
molto bene Ho studiato tutto il suo caso
e lei ha 34 anni è nata nel 1989 Io ho
34 anni sono nata nel 1800 nel 1989 è
lei è una coraggiosattivista per i
diritti umani in Arabia Saudita io sono
una mi definisco coraggiosa attivista
siciliana lei nel 2015 è stata arrestata
per la prima volta perché ha tentato di
attraversare il confine dagli Emirati
Arabi alla
all'arabia Saudita in auto
mi chiedete perché è stata arrestata
stava attraversando un confine in auto
nel 2015 alle donne ancora non era
consentito guidare un'autovettura in
Arabia Saudita
io nel 2015 mi ero appena laureata avevo
tutte le paturnie di questo mondo su
cosa sarebbe stata la mia vita però nel
frattempo avevo una vita agiata ed era
un attivista per i diritti umani
nel 2018 è stata arrestata nuovamente
per la sua attività di promozione dei
diritti umani e dei diritti delle donne
in Arabia Saudita le accuse erano quelle
di terrorismo contatti con le
organizzazioni internazionali e protesta
terrorismo perché protestava
pacificamente
solo nel febbraio del 2021 è stata
liberata
ha subito terribili violazioni diritti
umani in carcere è stata torturata è
stata ha subito abusi sessuali è uscita
È più bella di prima e più raggiante di
prima ed è sempre coraggiosa io l'ho
seguita e mi sono mortificata per
essermi definita attivista per i diritti
umani perché lei è attivista per i
diritti umani io non lo ero
avevamo due vite parallele stessa età
stessi stesse passioni in fondo Perché
tutte e due attiviste per i diritti
umani Eppure lei aveva fatto qualcosa io
cosa stavo facendo pensavo di aver fatto
grandi cose in realtà ben poco
e allora lei mi ha insegnato a capire
quali sono le mie potenzialità io cosa
potevo fare come potevo utilizzare la
mia posizione per cambiare il mondo
utilizzare i miei privilegi per spiegare
nel mio territorio notoriamente lo
sappiamo Qual è il nostro territorio
siciliano abbiamo l'abitudine anche di
lamentarci parecchio da noi non va in
mente Bene
bene in questo stesso territorio vediamo
già mille problemi e che comunque voglio
una nota positiva e che comunque sta
andando meglio
Va sempre meglio lenti Ma va sempre
meglio Ecco la nota positiva
va sempre data
lei ho capito che dovevo utilizzare i
miei privilegi per dare voce A chi voce
non ha la narrazione doveva cambiare
perché parlare di diritti umani come
qualcosa come un documento
scritto depositato all'onu che gente
importante dalle poltrone dalle loro
importanti poltrone ha firmato
ratificato ogni tanto se lo leggono
era povero Dovevo parlare di persone
perché i diritti umani riguardano le
persone e quindi il mio privilegio era
quello di avere voi come tante altra
gente a cui poter parlare a cui poter
raccontare storie di altre persone che
lottano ogni giorno e rischiano la loro
vita per la tutela dei diritti umani
E allora il cambio di narrazione era
quello anche la necessità di cambiare
narrazione era anche quella di cambiare
l'ordine valoriale che abbiamo nella
nostra quotidianità
attraverso un cambio di prospettiva
vi faccio un esempio
voi tu
sacrificeresti la tua vita per
l'ambiente adesso sono tornati in Auge
no i diritti ambientali Bene bene se ne
parla ok Ma quanti di voi seriamente
metterebbero a rischio la propria vita
per un lago
questa domanda
è stata posta da un bambino di quinta
elementare
a lui Martin
è venuto È stato un mio ospite a Termini
Imerese
perché lui è l'esponente del milpa è un
movimento che si occupa della tutela del
territorio che è stato assegnato al
popolo che abita alla Pas un territorio
una parte del territorio dell'Honduras
loro lottano per la tutela dell'ambiente
raccontava ai ragazzi Quello che rischia
ogni giorno lui i suoi colleghi uccisi a
un certo punto un bambino perché
tutelavano l'ambiente si battevano per
la tutela dell'ambiente e nella specie
anche per evitare che le multinazionali
costruissero una diga all'interno delle
riserve a un certo punto un bambino
nella sua piena onestà e sincerità dice
Ma scusami Martin Matte chi lo fa fare
cioè tu rischi la vita per un lago per
un pezzo di terra e lui rispose Ma tu
vuoi bene a tua madre e il bambino ma sì
certo che voglio bene a mia madre e tu
non rischieresti la vita per tua madre e
lui sì certo è la Terra è nostra madre è
un dovere per noi rischiare la nostra
vita per salvare la terra
Ecco il cambiamento dell'ordine
valoriale la società occidentale non ha
come nella scala dei valori al primo
posto l'ambiente alla libertà di parole
i diritti civili e politici per
eccellenza ma non questo tipo di diritti
e però è importante parlarne e però è
importante sentire l'oro che raccontano
la loro percezione per me fu la prima
volta che nonostante
attivista per i diritti umani continua
sempre a stupirmi fu la prima volta che
ho capito la diversità di percezione dei
valori
Altra domanda
e se fossi condannato per avere
protestato pacificamente
quante di voi quando sentono un annuncio
e una mobilitazione gli arriva l'invito
su Facebook piuttosto che su altri
social
è diciamo guarda partecipo che bello
questo flash mob partecipo la prima cosa
a cui pensate è che Rischiate di essere
condannati o incarcerati
qui no
c'è chi però questa paura ce l'ha ed è
quella di nawall da wolvena issa è un
attivista marocchina che lotta per avere
affinché nel territorio del Riff
arrivino
tutta una serie di servizi che
attualmente non ci sono basilari come
per esempio quelli sanitari
navale è venuta è venuta qua in Sicilia
ha raccontato la sua storia e anche lì
nelle scuole e anche lì un ragazzo
liceale gli ha chiesto una wal ma visto
che la gente scompare
viene screditata in un territorio dove
comunque molte informazioni non arrivano
quindi quando c'è lo screditamento da
parte della polizia locale è un danno
che si fa terribile all'immagine degli
attivisti dice Ma chi te lo fa fare
nawall Ma tu davvero rischi la tua vita
perché cosa per avere un ospedale di cui
tu neanche tu hai bisogno stai bene dice
Io lo faccio per
Perché un mio dovere lasciare un mondo
migliore per i miei figli e non solo per
i miei figli ma i miei figli dei vicini
e i miei concittadini perché se io non
lo faccio chi lo fa
Hai paura di finire in carcere per un
post
tutti noi abbiamo un profilo Facebook
Instagram in qualsiasi Social potrei
sciorinare ormai aumentano da ultimo
birreria Insomma ce ne sono tantissimi e
anche attraverso non solo attraverso le
parole ma anche attraverso le immagini
si esprimono idee opinioni tutti Ci
sentiamo liberi di fare quello che
vogliamo di criticare chiunque e lo
facciamo normalmente con una facilità
quasi disarmante perché Social del ci
hanno del responsabilizzato Ma in ogni
caso lo facciamo senza avere paura
purtroppo in alcuni paesi
questa paura è concreta perché questa
paura conduce a 22 mesi se non di più
come quelli che ha scontato Patrick di
detenzione preventiva senza che si possa
accedere ad una regolare giustizia senza
che possa essere esercitato in maniera
corretta il diritto di difesa Patrick
poteva essere chiunque di noi Chiunque
ha in famiglia un parente un fratello un
figlio che si sposta per andare in un
altro Ateneo per studiare e completare i
suoi studi è specializzarsi in una
materia egizia in una determinata ambito
e Patrick zaki era venuto a Bologna per
fare il master per studiare per
specializzarsi finito l'esame contento
tornava a casa dei suoi genitori quanta
gente conosciamo che fa questo che ha
questa prassi no bene anche lui stava
tornando a casa Peccato che nel febbraio
del 2020 è stato arrestato detenuto
scomparso che sapeva più niente Dopo
otto ore di interrogatorio Si è saputo
qualcosa era stato imprigionato e si è
fatto 22 mesi di detenzione ma la cosa
che è una pratica comune in Egitto
perché sono tantissimi prigionieri le
carceri egiziane sono pienissime di
studenti universitari giornalisti
avvocati Ma si sono estesi anche a
tantissimi altre fasce di popolazione
che è
imprigionano queste persone con una
detenzione preventiva e i processi sono
lunghissimi le udienze vanno di 45
giorni di 45 giorni rinviate perché
l'obiettivo dello Stato egiziano è
quello dell'oblio cioè vogliono che noi
ci stanchiamo di parlare dei Patrick
sono un certo diciamo ancora Patrick in
cava ancora studiense che vengono
rinviate basta ma non finisce mai a un
certo punto ci stanchiamo non scendiamo
più in piazza non ne parliamo più non
condividiamo più post e cade l'oblio
come suo padre come se
tantissima altra gente Patrick Adesso è
fuori per fortuna dopo 22 mesi di
detenzione il 7 dicembre del 2021 è
stato scarcerato Patrick Però non si può
muovere Perché le persone non sono
alberi non hanno radici Ma vogliono
camminare vogliono potersi spostare il
processo non è finito Patrick non può
spostarsi
padre che ancora non è assolto Patrick
vuole Libertà per un reato per delle
accuse che non ha commesso ok
e tornando a attivista per i diritti
umani o supereroi
sentendo tutte queste persone in realtà
si pensa si potrebbe pensare che cavolo
Avete visto per i diritti umani in
realtà sono dei supereroi the factono
Eppure così non è io ho cercato la
soluzione alla mia
alla mia Diciamo capacità argomentativa
di raccontare i diritti umani altrove
dimenticando che in realtà mia nonna mi
aveva dato questi insegnamento cioè mia
nonna mi aveva detto Mi dice sempre la
migliore
arma per cambiare il mondo è l'esempio
in un duplice non duplice Valenza
l'esempio che ti danno gli ai buoni
esempi e gli altri ma il buon esempio
che puoi dare tu perché il dare voce A
chi voce non ha ci consente di cambiare
il mondo e non pretendere che qualcuno
lo cambi perché vogliamo il cambiamento
del mondo ma esserne parte e se ne
attori perché se ognuno di noi lo
facesse realmente
concretamente Allora certamente il mondo
cambierebbe Grazie
[Musica]